- [Announcer] This UCSD TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language. But
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Leslie] So, one thing that I sort of
noticed this afternoon is the number of
times some of my earlier workers have been
criticized and that's good, that's normal.
It shows how the field is growing and
developing and building. And I've been
asked to talk about the evolution of human
life history patterns. And this is also a
reasonably new approach to study in human
evolution and we can understand a lot
about the evolution of the genus Homo by
looking at life history and by looking at
modern people. So basically, life history
is more than just looking at the evolution
of the physical body form. What it is is
looking at how we got to this body form.
Life history is your tempo and mode of
growth and development. And if you look
across the primates, you'll find a variety
of different patterns. And if we delve a
little bit into life history, as I said,
we can learn a tremendous amount about
ourselves. And it starts out in childhood.
You have a difference in the growth and
development pattern that's very obvious.
For example, chimpanzees all mature by the
time they're about 12 years old. For
humans it takes up until your late teens,
17, 18 years old. And our colleague, Barry
Bogan, has been very clear about the tempo
differences that you have if you compare a
chimpanzee with a human. The chimpanzee
graph there shows that you have a rapid
decline in the velocity of growth. A
relatively small plateau period, that's
the juvenile period. And then another
relatively rapid decline in how fast
you're growing. Humans are very different
in the corner. We have that same decline
in the velocity of growth but we have a
much longer plateau period where our
children are not growing very rapidly.
And this is followed by the adolescent
growth spurt and then it falls off again.
This pattern is very unique and it's very
important to our evolution. The last graph
is from the work of Kristin Hawkes who's
here in the audience. It shows you not
only do you have the difference in the
pattern of the growth but we also have a
very much longer longevity or life span.
Now what I find fascinating particularly
about the early childhood growth is that
it has a lot to do with the brain. We know
that humans have brain sizes about three
times the size of a chimpanzee and that
brain grows and develops at different
paces in the two species. Now in humans,
as a child is growing, a very young child
with a huge head uses about 60% of the
energy budget just to support that brain
size. And as we grow and our body begins
to grow, the brain growth slows down and
the energy balance tips. One of our
colleagues, Chris Kozawa, has come up with
I think is a brilliant look at the
relationship between this brain growth and
body growth. In these graphs, the red
line, one for males, the second graph for
females. The red shows the energy that the
brain takes as you move from birth up
through five years of age that is one of
the most energy expensive periods of brain
growth in childhood because of all the
mileazation that's going on and then it
drops off. The blue line is the velocity
of your somatic growth, your body growth.
So basically there's almost a perfect play
off between brain growth and somatic
growth. And this goes terribly long ways
to explaining why we have this extended
period of childhood that basically
correlates and is a necessary correlate in
energetic terms with the growth and
development of the large human brain
cells. Now we all may think this is fine
and good but it's actually not. So some of
our other colleagues from Switzerland,
Karin Isler and Carel van Schaik have
developed something they called the gray
ceiling. And what the importance of this
is you can just take so long in your
growth and development or you aren't going
to be able to replace your population
size. Now think in terms of dependent
childhood and if a child is dependent on a
mother for five years, six years, seven
years, she's going to come back into
fertility. You're going to extend that
inter birth interval. You aren't going to
be able to have enough surviving children
to replace your population from one
generation to another generation. Okay,
this is what they call the gray ceiling.
And if you look at the graph here, there
is a lot of primates. The red dots are the
apes with the increasing brain size. And
what this shows is that with some of our
apes like the orangutans, the gorillas and
all, what they're arguing is they're
hitting the gray ceiling and the only way
to avoid that gray ceiling is to somehow
increase your reproductive output. Now if
we go back to that same little chart I
chose earlier, at the bottom is the period
of infancy. And in chimpanzees, infants
are dependent on their mother, they're
still nursing. They are four to four and a
half years old before they're weaned. In
humans, it's of course very much shorter
and this particular graph shows about two
years, it varies. But what the take home
message of this is is you can have twice
as many kids if you shorten that period of
infancy. And if you then shorten your
interval between birth. Now again you may
think this is fine, this is a good trick,
we've all developed it, but it has
tremendous problems. And I've got this
picture hanging in my office and whenever
I think I'm having a hard day I think of
her. Because what you have once you start
to double up this is you have a woman who
may be pregnant. The infant that she's
probably in the last stage of nursing and
a dependent kid. And she has to get the
food to support her own large body weight,
her own large brain size, and to provide
all of the calories for the kids she's
nursing. She has to provide the food for
the young infant. Now this is very
different from what we see in the
chimpanzees or other apes where mothers
focus on one infant. And once the infant
has stopped nursing they will gather their
own food. There's very little energetic
involvement with the mother. Now this is a
huge paradox and this is where the
evolution of sharing and cooperation comes
in. And of course this is where we have
the grandmother hypothesis and the
argument that a lot of the extra resources
for the grandkids come from the
grandmother by provisioning the mother and
the kids. Now there's a number of other
arguments also that involved greater
cooperation among all individuals in the
society, males as well as sibling care and
sibling cooperation. The take home message
is that once you begin to develop a large
brain size, you have growth and
development implications. And these growth
and development implications have
implications for the evolution of what we
would recognize as a human type of
cooperative social organization. Okay, the
big question is, can we tell when this all
happened in human evolution? And we'd like
to think, oh, this is a characteristic of
the root of the genus Homo, that's a
hypothesis. Now if we go back to the
evolutionary tree, we have one way into
this in terms of cooperation. And if we go
back to the gray ceiling and I know Burden
isn't going to like my brain size against
a million year graph. But if we put the
gray ceiling onto this and again what
Isler and van Schaik argue is that gray
ceiling is about 700 milliliters. Now of
course there is, you know, big ranges of
variation around this, but what's
interesting about this is this just about
divides our Homo erectus from the earlier
hominids. And if we put it on our
evolutionary tree here, it comes at this
very interesting time between two million
and one million years ago where you have a
proliferation of hominids, a variety of
different species, and you have this big
variation in the brain sizes that we have.
Now as we've also heard, this time period
correlates with the radical change in
human adaptation. And particularly in
evidence for the precedence of animal
based tissues in the diet, it also
correlates again with our Turkana boy here
and this general time period where you
have the evolution of what we call Homo
erectus. Now what's interesting about this
also is it also correlates with the time
period where hominids begin to move out of
Africa. So our question here is how much
does this cooperative behavior that we can
infer from the brain size and we can refer
from the life history really affect the
hominid's ability to adapt to a variety of
different habitats not only in Africa but
also throughout the world? Now the only
direct evidence we have for any type of
cooperation comes from the side of Dmanisi
and our friend here with no teeth. And I'm
sure it feels very familiar with the
argument that this individual must have
whatever you want to argue, been taken
care of. The message from this is we don't
really know how to recognize this
cooperation in the fossil record. It would
be very nice if we could. Now if we come
back to the fossils, is there any way from
the fossils we could tell what their tempo
of growth is? And in this case, one of our
colleagues, Chris Dean, has been working
on how to infer growth and development
from the formation of the teeth. I've been
very impressed by some recent work by
Chris and his colleague, Helen Livesidge
in London. Not on teeth this time in
particular, but on body size because what
Chris has done is sort of bracketed the
age of our Turkana boy at death to
somewhere between seven and eight years
old. Now what these graph show were really
startling to me because the green one is
stature. And the histogram is the stature
of modern human kids who are between about
7 and 10 years old. The red line there is
the estimate for the Turkana boy. It's way
in excess of the stature that you would
expect. The blue is body mass or body
weight. Again way outside of what you
would expect in modern human kids. Now
what does this tell you about the growth
and development of the Turkana boy? If we
go back to Barry Bogan's figures, what
it's telling you is that the Turkana boy
was growing on a trend very much more
similar to the apes than to modern humans.
And if you look on the chart, in fact just
above age there on the chimp chart is
eight years old. And you've come out of
that plateau of slow growth velocity, the
individual would be then growing towards
his adult weight. In humans, it would be
still well within that plateau before that
growth explosion, that's the adolescent
growth spurt. Now this, to me, is very
convincing evidence that the Turkana boy
was not growing and developing on the
human pattern. Now what that would mean is
that it would reach maturity much more
rapidly than if it was growing on the
modern human sort of tempo and mode. Now
is there anything more we can tell? Your
eruption of teeth tends to still also
measure how long your growth period is.
And what's become very clear recently is
there's a tremendous amount of overlap not
only between living human tooth eruption
and tooth formation patterns and apes, but
also overlap in the fossil hominids. And
when it comes down to it, if you're
looking at tooth formation, your best
tooth in terms of distinguishing us
between the chimps and humans is your
third molar. But again the take home
message from this comes in the bottom
graph. And the blue line there is the
tooth development for your second premolar
and that's in the chimps, the red one is
in humans. The vertical lines are your
early Homo fossils. The green one is the
Turkana boy. And although the teeth are
developing at the very, very fast end of
modern humans and there's a tremendous
amount of variation, it's squarely within
the ape pattern as well. And if we're
going to argue about what the life history
patterns of some of these early Homo are,
basically we're talking about a much more
ape-like growth and development pattern
than a human-like growth and development
pattern. Okay, the next questions comes in
is when did we start to grow and develop
as humans? And the first indication is
with Homo antecessor which is about a
million, not .9 million years old. The
teeth are still developing more rapidly
than ours, meaning they're developing more
rapidly. But the argument is made that the
first ones that are closer to modern
humans than to the early Homo, the early
australopithecine pattern. And then as we
move up to the top at about a 160,000
years ago at the Moroccan side of Jebel
Irhoud and this is some of some John Jack
Hublin's and his group right there in the
fourth row, where you have a very modern
human growth and development pattern. Now
what I want to do is sort of finish with
what is probably everybody's favorite
fossil and that's the neanderthals. And
they're a long way up the record from what
we're talking about in the evolution of
the genus Homo. But I think the lessons we
can learn from the neanderthal growth and
development, we can usefully bring down
the record and apply to some of the
australopithecines. Now neanderthals of
course are the alternatives to modern
humans. They have brain sizes that overlap
with ours. They are in the blue series of
Xes there. They lived in Europe during the
last ice age while anatomically modern
humans were evolving elsewhere in Africa.
What, again, another piece of evidence
that struck me that comes out of Martin
Gonzales and some of his colleagues' work
from Spain is the growth and development
of the little neanderthal kids. So the
blue lines here are your growth from not
years, up to 70 months. The horizontal
lines are the equivalently aged
neanderthals in relation to that modern
human growth pattern. So here you can say
the little neanderthals are basically
plateauing much earlier than you would see
in the human growth curve. Now think about
being a neanderthal. I'm often happy I
wasn't born a neanderthal because, you
know, what the authors are arguing here is
not only do they have the energetic stress
of growing and developing that large
human-like brain size, they also have a
serious thermoregulatory problem. Because
in fact with Steve Churchlin I've done
some modeling on the energetic
requirements in neanderthals and it's
about the same as to say somebody riding
the Tour de France in the Alps. It's about
500 kilocalories a day. And you think of
these poor little neanderthals trying to
support that brain and also keep warm. Now
there is a second piece also that comes
from other research. This is from Smith et
al in 2010. And the green lines here are
your expected and predicted ages for human
teeth and the blue lines are the
neanderthals. The take home message is
their teeth are developing more rapidly so
they have a more attenuated growth and
development process. Now coming back to
this and where you would expect to say a
modern human populations to have more
rapid growth and development. It's in
situations where you have a higher
mortality rate. Now think about these poor
neanderthals, they have a very high
mortality rate, every three calistosis.
It's the same as rodeo riders in the
southwest. And you have these poor little
stressed neanderthals with a shorter body
size. Now if we come back to all of our,
you know, fossil species, our
australopithecines and early Homo, living
in a period of very fluctuating climate in
Africa, and this little zig-zag chart is
just from East Africa, but also
experiencing all of these environments
around the world. What we really want to
know is what their growth and development
patterns are and how these reflect what's
happening in their lifestyle. And what I
tend to think is that the same processes
that affect us today were also affecting
them. And this is a huge challenge, it's
very exciting research and I think as soon
as we're able to screw down into it, we're
going to find similar neanderthal-like
patterns among the hominids that are
living different types of lifestyles. To
end, I'd like to thank CARTA. We were all
having a great time here. And I'd
particularly like to thank all of the
attendees of a Wandergrand conference,
some of you are sitting in the audience
here, that we held on human biology and
the origins of Homo. And a lot of these
life history ideas were developed in a
week-long meeting in Portugal. So thank
you very much.
♪ [music] ♪